[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life we do
that by helping you win in your money in
your work and in your relationships I'm
Ken Coleman joined by George camel my
good pal and the author of a soon to be
release
book and it's a good one we'll talk
about that
coming up but the phone number to jump
in is 8825 5225
5225 let's go you ready George I'm
stoked all right oh you're stoked did
you put your skateboard under that's
what the Young Folks say yeah okay I
that's very interesting you're stoked
well let's go to Stephen in Charlotte
North Carolina Stephen I'm Ken George is
stoked how can we help you hi George and
Ken how are you today we're having a
blast what's up all right all right guys
um so George a special thank you first
off for you know reaching out to me
um on the show George is calling callers
now what is happening feels like we have
a boundary St he sent me a DM yesterday
with his question I said hey I want to
dig into this will you call the show
this is a perfect call for Ken and I to
take I want to hear Ken's thoughts so we
we got him scheduled and I'm so elated
that he was able to call you really are
a man of the people you are a man of the
people exctly happened right there all
right Ste what's going
on all right guys so um as I mentioned
to George um I'm a former uh lottery
winner um I a million dollars a million
dollars yeah a million dollars on a
scratch ticket um wow in the state of
Virginia when I was 28 and I'm
36 nice now and I have gone through it
all um oh down to zero yeah so I am a
part of that statistic that uh I don't
know 80 or 90% of lottery winners lose
it um I swore that I wouldn't be but
here I am and uh what was your take it
what was the take home after the yeah
766 th000 was what the actual ticket was
worth it wasn't actually worth a million
dollars I know that's what they
advertise right and then I paid taxes on
that so take home was
$555 okay and over the span of eight
years you drain that 555 in your bank
account to
zero yes sir can you for the the benefit
of the listeners and a dark curiosity
can you tell us where that money
went yeah so I mean obviously I bought
the ticket so I gambled to buy the
ticket right um so that that never
stopped um was more so with casinos uh
Sports gambling Etc um quite embarrassed
by it
um you know absolutely well this is
clearly there's uh addictive behavior
here have you dealt with that over the
last eight years are you still grappling
with
that yes um I've reached out to Gamblers
Anonymous um I actually have an
appointment set up uh to speak with
someone uh to hopefully get get me over
the addiction and and move forward is
this the first step you've taken as
we're talking now what's that is that
the first step you've taken to get
control of
this yes and I realized that it was an
issue um but you know still would still
would go at it wow so would you say it
was largely gambling did you buy you
know a house a car upgrade your
lifestyle definitely upgraded the
lifestyle I a little bit I did buy a new
car um I PID cash for it uh when I won
um I PID off my debts um except for one
I had two student loans um I did not pay
off the federal student loan I paid off
the private student loan um and that's
the that's the debt that I carry today I
don't I don't have a car debt okay well
we're going to help you take the right
Next Step we're not here to beat you up
um we know you're you've been dealing
with this Addiction on top of now kind
of being at rock bottom so lay it out
for us are you working right now and
what's your
income yes sir um I'm in restaurant
management my income is 75,000 good and
how much debt do you have
left um 29,000 all right and how much
money do you have in the bank if
any uh about
6,000 okay that's good news and are you
single I have a girlfriend um not
married but I have a girlfriend and we
do live together okay and the 29,000 is
that one student loan or a bunch of
student loans what kind of debt is that
it's two different uh federal student
loans that total the 29,000 okay so we
can start to chip away at that with some
of the savings you have your $1,000
emergency fund now we're going to debt
snowball these pretty quickly making 75
knocking out 29 how quickly could you do
that well I have roughly 2400 a month
left over after all bills paid um so you
know divide that into the roughly 30
grand so what 15 months 16 months yeah
you'll be done with this in under a year
I mean 2400 month that's 29 Grand in a
year so let's focus on knocking this out
over the next 12 months then we're going
to get a fully fun emergency fund so
that you never have to go back into debt
again so you have Financial Foundation
but the bigger piece is getting our
spending under control and getting this
addiction under
control yeah yeah I I don't really spend
all that much I I don't live a high
fluen lifestyle I just I gamble you know
and that's that's where it's have you
have you cut off the the ability to
gamble whether it's your friend group
whether it's the cards whatever it is
that's enabling you to do this have you
cut those pieces
off I don't really know how to cut I
have a couple of friends that that are
well aware of what's going on
um and you know we've spoken in detail
and are they the kind of people that
will challenge you hold you accountable
check in on you will you be honest with
them could you listen to
them absolutely yeah they they have done
that um we haven't spoken recently we
had a conversation about six months ago
um about all of it um I I haven't
stopped since then um do you have any
credit cards open no sir okay what are
you what are you gambling on right now
is it football or or what what is it
yeah I'll do sports sports gambling um
is that through an app or
website no it's just live okay because
the one thing you can do is delete all
the apps delete all your logins all your
payment info for all these sites you can
block these sites too through your
browser yeah I think we need to put some
self aware steps in place I think George
is Right Stephen I I think you have to
do that but you have to have some
accountability like your girlfriend like
it would be like Gamblers Anonymous will
help with that for sure it will but but
I think you need to decide today I I I'm
not again in any way taken away from
therapy or anything else but I I I do
think you need some accountability and I
would almost treat your gambling like I
would a teenager looking at stuff they
shouldn't look at on a phone and I would
get the girlfriend involved or a really
close friend and set it up to where they
set it up where there's notifications or
something there's got to be a way to do
this but at the end of the day going to
have to just decide can I wean myself
off of this can I watch can I go through
one weekend one weekend at a time can I
just go through a weekend and not
gamble yeah and I've you know I've
always been um I've always held myself
accountable in all areas of life um
except this one you except yeah except
this also here's the deal it's
frustrating I know it's frustrating and
I and again I think you need help and I
I would absolutely go and get with a
therapist I would I I'd make that uh I'd
make a couple phone calls today I think
you need to take action on this and also
some accountability and you know what
else I think you ought to put that
competitive fire into making some more
money I'm going to challenge you
professionally what are two or three
rungs up the professional ladder for you
uh give yourself a challenge to go make
more money by growing professionally
thanks for the call appreciate your
honesty Stephen we're going to walk with
you on this this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
help you win in your life with your
money your work and your relationships
I'm Ken he is George over there say hi
to America George hi and we are here for
youle 8825
5225 felt like your child that's not how
that I that's not how I expected that to
play out it felt like you 10-year-old
yeah you were egging that Vibe on so I
went with it it's called improv well uh
you know George I knew you when you were
single that's true and uh so tomorrow
this would have been a day uh that would
be an exciting day for you but
thankfully thankfully you uh somehow
coerced Whitney what day is this into
it's called singles day are you aware of
this never heard of there's every
there's a day for everything and in my
hands
here uh I have got a announcement for uh
1111 known as singles day the largest
shopping day in the world and uh people
are always looking for an excuse to
spend money that's your area so we just
made a holiday to make it happen so we
jumped in on it why not get in on the
fun it's happening so Dave said get get
there so what we're doing is a one- day
sale only on Saturday you can get our
bestselling books like Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaire uh from
paycheck to purpose own your past change
your future for just $11 wa okay this is
pretty meta cuz we have the 12 $1 sale
but just for one day only you get a
dollar off yeah and it's not just if
you're single now it's aimed at the
singles but truth be told quite sure why
we can't police that on the website we
can't so um there you go and you can
also get my get clear assessment the
digital for 11 bucks for $11 that's
normally 30 I don't know how my kids are
going to eat next month I'm going to
talk to Dave about this I'm not happy at
all that's too steep of a discount but
you the people win as usual so it's $11
sale all over the website ramsy
solutions.com
ramsy solutions.com store I have no idea
what singles day had to do with that
unbelievable offer just one more reason
to celebrate K my job is to read it's
time for the Ramy da notes the Ramy
dating app that's the next one k we will
never make from Singles day to the City
of Brotherly Love Chris is joining us
now in Philadelphia Pennsylvania Chris
you're on the Ramy show how can we
help Ken George thanks for taking my
call how are you
today we're good we're sorry I got a
little chuckle chuckle going on here
what can we do for you sure uh so I'm
giving you a call here because
unfortunately it appears that I'll be
losing my job here in the very near
future oh no what's going on I'm sorry
what's happening uh my my company's
experiencing some financial difficulties
um they had a lower interest rate for a
very long time and like most individuals
uh they they work off of debt as a
company um so are you in the financial
sector I am in the pharmaceutical sector
small pharmaceutical company oh wow uh
so their debts they they can't keep up
with they've uh off boarded about 20% of
the company and I think I'm uh I'm
coming due is this like in a week or is
this a month you have any idea of the
timeline it could be anywhere from a
week to the next month that's correct
okay and you are certain that you have
already been selected to be laid off I'm
90% conf confident that it'll it'll
occur okay what do you
make uh currently I make 135,000 with a
10% targeted bonus so about 150,000 a
year uh but I am married and have a
one-year-old daughter as well my wife is
uh fortunately a uh teacher making
$70,000 a year and she has tenure so at
minimum we have that going for us is
that enough to cover the bills if it was
just her income I'll a super majority of
those bills I'll tell you George we uh
we live very with our PSE strings very
tight um our basic needs we run at about
40% of our budget um our savings and
debt reduction we've been going crazy at
46% and we live with AAL 15% of our ni
to haves uh through our budgeting okay
so how much Deb do you have persective
uh we have
$110,000 left and it is our mortgage and
that is it oh okay so no Consumer Debt
and the mortgage is reasonable as a part
of your take-home pay it is $1,800 a
month um and we as a total from a net
perspective bring home approximately uh
hold on uh $122,000 wonderful okay so
you are in a a solid financial position
which gives me great joy during this
time of stress that you're going to be
okay financially and so now it's up to
you to find that next job which Ken is
he's the man for that yeah so what do
you do in
Pharmaceuticals sure uh I'm a
transparency specialist um the
pharmaceutical industry has a very Niche
uh requirement through the government
it's a compliance role but essentially
we look at Financial transactions and uh
disclose payments to doctors it's a very
Niche uh area but I've also worked in
finance for six years so I'm covered
across the financial and pharmaceutical
industry I've been putting my resume out
for about a month here and I have not
received the uh
the requests to interview as I would
like to rehashing my resume here well
that's fine and and I love that and
we've got a free resume guide which I'll
make sure uh that we get to you uh at
the end of our call it's a free resource
we've also got some great templates
that'll help you stand out but um you
are exhibit a on this idea of I'm just
going to throw a bunch of resumés out
there um it is very very hard to get
noticed in today's world because of two
factors number one
almost every company is using some form
of artificial intelligence to filter
through
resumés and so you're kind of playing
the resume Lottery you know or the slot
machine if if one word's not right and
you know what I'm talking about the
second thing that's going on is is um a
lot of high demand people are looking
for the higher paid positions and so you
need the edge and the edge is this the
personal connection so what you need to
be doing right now this is old school
but I mean this is a piece of paper a
notebook you can create a spreadsheet if
you feel more comfortable doing on a
computer but you've got to start looking
at the the jobs you've already applied
for you already sent resumés out um they
may have moved on maybe they haven't but
with those as examples you want to start
asking yourself you make a list of these
companies and you say do I know somebody
that works in that building or Works in
a building connected to that building
right the idea is do I know anybody that
works for that organization question one
question two is do I know somebody that
knows somebody over there and what we're
attempting to do here is we've got to
get through the hiring filter the AI and
all of that stuff we've got to get
somebody who takes your resume Chris to
the hiring manager says here's how I
know Chris I've known Chris since high
school we played blank together or
whatever whatever whatever right or I've
got a really good friend who knows this
guy Chris and the guy's really
qualified and he applied online hadn't
gotten anything yet I think you ought to
look at him uh it is it is that kind of
exercise and then you got to be talking
to everybody that you run into I mean
you run into a parent at a basketball
practice you're talking to them getting
to know them they're going to say what
do you do you tell them what's going on
I'm looking for something like this you
have got to make getting an opportunity
for an interview a full-time Focus that
has to be the game and there's it's
pretty simple but that's what you've got
to be doing right now and in the
meantime I would also be plotting out
what happens if I don't get a job
interview George uh before I get laid
off so I'm looking at side hustles
things that would be the gig economy is
there any freelance work available for a
guy like you with a lot of Finance
background is there any freelance work
in your specific Niche work probably not
but that's what I'm looking at I'm
looking at what I have from a skill
standpoint and an experience standpoint
that allow me to make some freelance
money so that if I get laid off and I
haven't landed a gig yet between my
wife's income how Frugal you guys are
any just even if it's 30 or 40% of what
you were making it just takes all the
stress away because you guys have been
so disciplined now I know I hit you with
a lot but a real quick question we've
only got about a minute about 45 seconds
do you want to stay in the role that
you're in if we were to find that for
you today would you stay in that or do
you want to move on take this
opportunity to move on
I I'd honestly love to go back into
Finance um but honestly the call and
question that I wanted to jump into uh
I'm going back to my contacts in finance
to to get a role uh strategically I know
that's what I'm going to be able to do
good tactically I'm looking at this and
I'm just asking obviously we need to
slow down our debt uh debt payment here
um moving down to just the core items um
that's correct sure that we're covering
you're in storm mode which means we're
pausing the baby steps let's stack up a
whole bunch of cash until we get
stability then we can move forward
you'll pay off that house in no time
that's right it's the only debt you've
got left you're in great shape and
you're very disciplined this is a blip
for you it's a bump in the road you're
going to be fine thanks for the call
Chris this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show well you've all played the
Telephone Game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us next
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
helping you win with your money winning
your work and winning your relationships
this is the Ramsey Show so excited to be
with you today I'm Ken Coleman George
camel is with me this hour and we have a
fantastic uh live studio audience in the
lobby really do a Rowdy Bunch we have to
contain them yeah no they're not very
Rowdy I love when you said rowy bunch
and there's one guy out there that was
like arms crossed and he like I'm Rowdy
they're a little miffed I'm Rowdy
they're a little miffed now cuz we
called attention to them they're on the
edge they're lovely people and uh
there's a lady waving at us ly L nice to
see you ma'am good to see you good
reminder that you can come visit us you
can come visit us and we have free
coffee free baked goods and and the
show's free Show's free and we come out
and take pictures with you whether you
want us to or not that's always not
awkward so you know that that whole
thing is great so uh to the phones we
gole 8825 5225 8825 5225 Emma joins us
in Los Angeles California Emma how can
we
help uh hi George hi Ken um I'm calling
because um I know you'll help knock some
sense to me um I'm in baby step
3B and I am hoping to start saving I
mean I'm saving for a home but here in
California like I'll have to save
$100,000 $100,000 to like just get in a
down payment so that my monthly payment
will ridiculously high and it'll take me
like two to three years to save for that
but I started to look into um this house
Pro this I'm sorry house buying process
and I qualify for like a loan of 500,000
but it's just going to be a high monthly
payment and I do have health
fever and I want to start planning for
my retirement so if I jump the gun and
pull the plug next year even though I
don't have the 100K yet you know I'm
just starting to save um I just feel
like I'm starting my retirement planning
kind of late and how old are you going
I'm 39 oh my goodness you're ancient
easy George I know 3 years from now
you're going to be 42 you can't tell
women that what's wrong with you you're
going to have to find a house with no
stairs I'm not sure you're going to be
able to walk up those you know they have
those things now you know they have
those little chairs that go slowly up
the stairs we could get her one of those
I do need a a one floor because I do
have arthritis and so I cannot imagine
myself going up I nailed it oh jeez
that's going to limit the housing
options already okay Emma let's walk
through this so there's this home buying
program is that what you're saying that
will allow you to put less down and
qualify for more loan yeah like if FHA
loan oh
gross okay so talk about house fever
first yeah the house fever uh I don't
know that I can squel you're frustrated
by High rent prices you want to be
putting your money towards something
building Equity instead of I'm quoting
this throwing away money on rent did I
nail
it yes of course you did okay so that's
very understandable I have a lot of
empathy for many people out there who
want to be homeowners they've been
working for a long time and they're
going this should just be possible for
me real quick and it feels impossible um
and I want you to walk through here but
I but on this fever issue I think I can
address the house fever all right hit me
because when I moved here um with our
family what nine years ago I got into
Williamson County and I started driving
around on the roads and I want to make
sure you hear this Emma and I got what
is known as land fever oh boy yeah yeah
that's full on Yellowstone oh boy I was
looking at large Parcels of land where
we could with a house or where we would
build and I just got in love with it and
I'm not kidding you there were two or
three nights a week I would on my way
home I would go check out things and my
wife would be like hey dinner's almost
ready where where are you and I like and
I'd FaceTime her I'm like look at this
you know and I was I'm not kidding I
really got into it so in in all
seriousness I know what it's like and so
what you have to do is what I had to do
I was not in a place financially to be
able to buy that but I was like I was
wishing and wishing and I got so sucked
into the wishing and the looking and
it's kind of like the old days where you
looked at a catalog you know and it's
just at some point you got to burn the
catalog throw the catalog away and I'm
telling you George is going to walk you
through this but I think it's really SM
that that you put some ice on this fever
and I think you got to stop thinking
about buying a house stop looking at
houses and be really laser focus because
we know from all kinds of scientific and
psychological data about the power of
focus uh give you an example uh you
remember the last time you bought a car
Emma do you remember that yes what was
the car a Toyota RAV for and what color
was that Toyota RAV for a silver silver
do you remember seeing a silver RAV fors
all over the road for the first three
four five days you remember that yeah
now we see them everywhere you see them
everywhere did the god fairy did the car
fairy just drop in Toyota RAV fors all
of a sudden on the
road the answer is no here's the
exercise what we focus on is what we see
everywhere and and the power of focus is
unbelievable and and I'm going to give
you right back to George on this because
the process he's going to walk you
through and this idea that oh I'm
wasting money on rent and I keep looking
at houses and I'm not ready to buy a
house but I know I'm not ready to buy a
house but I'm going to find this little
program that'll make me ready to buy a
house when in all reality you're not
ready to buy a house and I wasn't ready
for the land back then I'm still not
ready for the land I want the good news
is I don't have land fever anymore
because guess what I'm not looking at
all the time George houses land land
Parcels I'm not looking at dirt you know
and so that's really important yeah well
Emma the problem with these programs and
what you're talking about for the
listeners benefit is the federal housing
Administration FHA loans and they're
designed for people who don't qualify
for conventional mortgages do you know
why they don't
qualify I'm assuming because they don't
have enough money because private
lenders are saying this is way too much
risk even for a lender to take on
they're going no thanks so the
government swoops in to be the Savior
allowing broke people to get into homes
for a little of 3 and a half% down which
sounds great but then think about this
that means you're financing
96.5% of that on top of something they
charge you called mortgage insurance
premium MIP
1.75% right there plus an annual premium
between 0.15% and 75% for the life of
the loan so they're they're you're
paying an extra stupid tax on top of
borrowing way more while you already
didn't have the money to afford the
mortgage payment and then here's what
happens Emma there's going to be a call
during this show where someone calls in
and says hi I'm calling from California
we bought too much house before we could
really afford it on one of these home
buyer programs we can't afford it
because it's now 70% of our take-home
pay is going toward this mortgage cuz we
thought this home was going to be a
blessing turns out it's a burden cuz now
the hvac's broken and we have no money
to fix it do you see where I'm going
with this yes yeah so I don't want that
to become you because I care about your
future too much and if that means Emma
has to rent for two more years than she
wanted to I'm okay with that yep renting
is buying patience I'm sick of people
telling you that renting is a sin and
wasting money and one more thing you
live in California and you're not held
hostage there you know I'm not saying
you have to go leave California if you
love it there and you have a good job
there that's great we have to remind
ourselves we're not stuck with where we
are I moved from Boston to mobile to
Nashville and uh depending on where you
live home ownership may not be in the
cards for the next 5 years or 10 years
if you live in Manhattan I don't know
that you're going to be a homeowner in
this lifetime in Manhattan cuz it's
insane and so we've got to start looking
at other options resetting expectations
maybe you're going to get a condo 30
minutes away instead of the single
family home in the town that you're in
and that's going to involve some
sacrifice that may mean we have a longer
commute to work and so we have to weigh
all of these options move with patience
and also look at what you can do to
speed up the process yeah look at
getting your income up is that a
possibility what do you
make I make about a 100,000 wonderful
income and you have any debt you you're
in baby step 3 so debt free what do you
do for a living
I do a little bit of I do like sales and
I do product group managing you know um
I'm telling you you need to be looking
at some gigs the gig economy which is
nothing more than freelancing I George
is right and of course I'm always going
to agree with him on hey how can we make
extra money to speed this timeline up
I'd put that that that anxiousness and
that uh house fever into money fever
freelance you're a professional make six
figures how can you freelance and make
an extra 3040
$50,000 that's what you need to be
focused on because all of a sudden we
fast forward everything and George is
right by the way George I love when you
get fired up people don't know people
don't know that what you just did was
your version of a rant cuz you're so
mellow but I thought it was great
appreciate that and I think you're right
what people don't realize is that
renting isn't wasting money it's
actually biting time and I think keeping
your options open as opposed to getting
too much house so really good rant
George run it back folks run it back and
watch it back he's seething you just
can't tell this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
apply
[Music]
[Applause]
n welcome back to the ramsy show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campbell joins me the
phone number for you to jump in today is
8825 5225 that's
8825 5225 okay um I don't know how many
people that are listening on watching
today pay attention to news
headlines or the news period I really
don't know that feels like a personal
attack on me Ken but it's fine you took
that personally how much news do you
watch not much sometimes I'll watch like
a late night show monologue just to
digest some of what happened in a fun
way but that's about it no kidding
unless Ken tells me about it are you not
on a News website well I'm busy in the
personal finance world you know being a
nerd well first of all I'm not judging
you but boy oh boy did you take that and
run with it I do uh but okay so George
is a prime example now I'm on the other
side of it you're always following the
news I'm paying attention to the news CU
somebody has to thank you Ken you went
first yeah I know so brave listen it is
what it is I like to know what's going
on so here's what's going on if you do
pay attention to the news now George
this will all be news to
you that was a good pun do you like that
golly Americans say the economy stinks
but they're spending like it's great
this is a headline from CNN wow I'm
holding here this article in my hands
strong headline and here here's what is
happening by the way I've been talking
about this so inflation has been high
for some time even though it is slowing
but still high that's a negative job
market really good we have 3.9%
unemployment Millions more jobs
available than there people who are
unemployed that's good wages are up
since the pandemic hourly wages and
salaries are up across the board so the
American people went all right we got
more money so let's spend it they didn't
save it there was a there was a little
bit of a in 2020 a prolonged season of
saving but that's gone people are
spending like drunken Sailors and it's
crazy 72% of all Americans say things in
the country today are going badly and 66
said the economy 66% of the economy will
be extremely important when deciding who
to vote for next year okay but the
problem is and the word is conundrum
used in the article which by the way is
is a word we don't use enough
underutilized it really is um because
they're spending money on concerts
there's spending money eating out
they're spending money on clothes
vacations vacations credit card at an
all-time high credit card debt at an
all-time high and by the way I don't
know if you saw this Mr Money news this
will be embarrassing for you if you
didn't see this so you should go ahead
and act like you saw this okay the
average APR the percentage rate on
credit cards reached an all-time high
last week with an average of 20.7 to5
O going to leave a mar so you're smart
like isn't that the equivalent of going
I'm going to go buy this but it's if I
use my credit card I'm actually paying
20% more oh absolutely I mean that's the
Prem people don't think that way well
Ken there's styed going well I'm going
to pay the balance off I'm going to get
my 2% cash back so I'm going to beat the
system Ken and here we are at record
high of $ 1.08 trillion in credit card
debt and you're going how are you guys
beating the system and everyone self
selects out and go k I'm smarter than
that but here we are spending like
Congress while then saying saying the
economy stinks and things are so bad and
yet we're out here I guess just with our
head in the sand spending like crazy to
cope with it um I got killed by the
snowflakes on H social media when I put
out an Instagram re saying your paycheck
is not your problem your budget is oo
and I got lamb Bast I can I guess what
they were saying they called me out of
touch millionaire you know all these
things like I've got my head in the sand
here's what I'm guessing did they say
let me guess what the comment section
I'm going to sum it up yeah but Ken
wages haven't kept up with inflation and
the guy in the White House and the fed
and the Boomers they' ruined the housing
market and therefore we'll never get
ahead and someone needs to do something
about this but it's not up to me it's up
to everyone else yeah did I sum it up
absolutely and then and then been how
out of touch I am except for paying
attention to what actually said was is
that if you can live on less than you
make and the real data from Ramsey
Solutions having pulled surveyed over
10,000 net worth millionaires the third
largest group being
teachers teachers aren't making bank
they're just living on lesson they make
George well they got very few people to
impress cuz they're just trying to
survive with these kids out here not
trying to pull up in the Beamer next to
the
uh soers there you go so I mean we're in
this day and age where everybody wants
to spin by the way can I make a just one
little comment on
the um my my pay isn't keeping up with
inflation sure I can't stop you thank
you very much
so a healthy inflation rate the FED
historically is trying to keep inflation
at a inflation growth rate of of 2 to 3%
Max okay so when people say idiotic
things like my pay isn't keeping up
inflation well most most of the time in
a normal inflationary season like where
that number kind of holds there in that
2 to 3% range the most companies are
giving people an annual raise of about
3% okay so that's where they get this
nonsensical idea that my pay has to
always keep up with inflation but when
we saw extraordinary inflation over the
last two or three years do do any of
these people realize that if if
companies had to try to keep up with the
inflation that all the companies would
got our business well the housing market
jumps 30% we can't all just
automatically get 30% raises cuz the
company Revenue didn't automatically
jump 30% and I want the youngster at
Burger King to make good money when he's
flipping the Whopper but when we got to
pay him three or four dollars an hour
guess what else goes up anybody the cost
of the Whopper the Whopper combo so
you're griping about how much you're
making and you're griping about how much
the food cost we've got to understand
basic economics in this country and
everybody wants what they want because
they want it they don't understand what
it takes to get it and it's not somebody
handing it to you it's you going and
getting it for crying out loud there's
my little that was your Gen X rant of
the day my gen thanks for calling it a
Gen X rant I can't call you a Boomer yet
no I would be very upset we couldn't be
friends if you called me a boomer anyway
back to the phones we go John in York
Pennsylvania John how can we
help hey guys um I have a question for
you so I have a sports car that I am
considering getting rid of or keeping um
and I wanted your advice on it tell us
about the
car it's a uh it's a Mustang it's worth
about 60 Grand actually going up in
value since I bought it
um9 what
what is the what year is the
Mustang it's a 2017
oh okay so tell us more do you have debt
on this yeah I owe about 15,000 more on
it right now um I could pay it off right
now if I wanted to um I'm just waiting
on a uh High interest rate um savings
account to uh time out before I go and
pay it off because I'm making more on
the money in the bank versus oh no John
that's broke people
talk that's some common core math right
there it just doesn't work oh I see what
you did there what's your payment on
this
thing uh it's about $1,000 a month okay
so let's just do some basic math you get
rid of this payment and you start
investing $1,000 a month don't you think
that's a better decision for your future
than hanging on to a car payment to make
a tiny spread in a savings
account well so that's my question
should I sell the car and take all my
equity in it and just that and be away
with it or should I keep it get away
with the payment and start to invest it
slowly how much Equity do you
have um well like I said it's worth
about 60 I've got about 15 left on it so
okay like 45k would be your profit you
buy yourself a little car is this your
only
car um no I I drive a a company I drive
a company truck for work that's fully
paid for by work and I if you want a
cool Mustang go get you something from
the 60s my young friend let me tell you
right now that's what I would do K we're
not looking for having an upgrade all
right we're trying to help him out no
I'm saying he cashes out and he saves
and then he gets himself a real mustach
that's some healthy profit well what's
your somebody has to tell him what do
you
make uh I make about 120 okay and what
uh other debt do you
have um my wife and I own a house um
that is worth about or our mortgage is
about 300,000 left on it okay so so far
you're not violating any principles if
your cars add up to more than half of
your annual income I'd go ahead and sell
it I still think because this is
Weighing on you and you called us it
sounds like selling this thing would be
a relief for you you can always go get a
car later on when you are a millionaire
and you got a paid for house that' make
me feel better yeah and again a Mustang
from the' 60s you pay cash thank you Ken
it's going to be a better thing and it's
worth something it's going to grow in
value not a 2017 all right we got to get
out of here good hour thanks James
Charles and everybody in the booth thank
you George thank you America this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
we help you win in your life
specifically winning with your money
your work and your
relationships 8825 5225 is the phone
number to jump in it's to free America
88255 225 I'm Ken Coleman George camell
joins me George is our money expert and
I'm your work expert today so those two
things go together a lot so you've got
any work questions if you're wondering
about why you've been passed over want
to get promoted you're feeling stuck not
sure which way to go in your career you
want to add some money Financial uh to
your uh baby steps rather uh due to
extra work I'm here to answer any work
rated questions as well so come on come
all we'd love to talk to you Nicole
starts us off this hour in Dallas Texas
no Nicole how can we
help hey guys thank you guys so much for
taking my call today um so this is kind
of what's going on um my dad
unfortunately relapsed on mess um and he
was supposed to take over my
grandfather's
business and with the relapse my
grandfather came to my husband and I and
said would you guys be willing to do
this when I pass he's in his 80s um and
the business is probably worth three to
five million and I just want to know
what I can do to protect this business
um and from the crazy family and grow
the wealth and and be
successful okay so do you want to take
over sounds like you
do yeah so I'm actually a nurse um and
my husband was active duty military he
just retired um it's a motorcycle
business motorcycle you guys sell repair
um so we sell the parts for
Harley-Davidson motorcycles yeah we
don't do any repair work we just sell
the parts very successful nice yeah it's
a very successful business all right and
so when you say Protect it from the
family you mean protect it from your dad
getting
it well my dad and and also my aunt and
uncle unfortunately all three of them
are addicts um one lives under a bridge
by his choice oh uh the other one lives
with various People couch surfing I mean
they're all in their 50s and 60s and
this is just what they've made of their
lives unfortunately all right
so am I right that if your
grandfather puts it in the will and all
of his documents and it's laid out that
you and your husband are going to be
inheriting the business you will be sole
uh owners of the business upon his death
does that not take care of that
issue um
well yes and no my my issue is my dad
tries to claim that the business is his
because he took out a
um like a soul proprietorship in Dallas
County for the name and so he's trying
to say it's his what does your
grandfather what does your grandfather
say about that
claim um not really anything he he says
not to worry about it but I do worry
about it well why I'm calling you guys
no no no and I appreciate that but I
mean it's you know I can claim to have
dunked a basketball in the 10th grade
but I can claim lots of crazy things I
never did dunk George sure no one
thought you did that's what I thought
never could quite get there I just
couldn't I tried but anyway so uh this
is an this is an easy fix this is we go
to Granddad and we say Granddad I know
you told me not to worry about it I want
to know that I know that I know that
this is locked up so when you say don't
worry about it why do you have some type
of documentation that supersedes my
dad's erroneous Soul proprietorship
claim like I would go ahead and get with
Granddad and say so that when you're
gone I'm celebrating you and your legacy
and taking it to the next level I don't
want to fight with my dad I don't want
to fight with my uncle my aunt and and
so let's get this locked up to where my
dad has no standing at all let's get a
lawyer involved and have your
grandfather show you the paperwork that
would override or whatever you need to
see with your eyeballs and talk to a
legitimate lawyer and know that this is
all settled and that your dad's claim is
bogus that's that's all that that's all
that you have to do 100% And this is
between your grandfather and your father
yeah you don't need to middle of this
your grandfather needs to communicate
all of this and and you need to say I'm
not taking over this business until we
have all of this in writing that this is
free and clear that we are the sole
owners that they will have no stake in
this before you step foot that's right
but this is a problem you know we can
only take it so far we are not
Professionals in that regard and great
advice George this is Granddad does this
granddad's got to talk to his grown son
who's a meth addict and he's going to
fix this mess cuz my guess he's not he's
not in the will to inherit anything let
alone the
business would I be correct yes okay
does that answer your question
Nicole yes that does and I will get with
him and see what he says it doesn't make
it any less a second wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait I heard a little
something there a little sass I no no
not sass I heard doubt I are you
doubtful that granddad's gonna take the
necessary steps to confront
this yes only because he has given my
father probably no no bsp guys probably
five businesses very nice businesses my
grandfather's always been an
entrepreneur and my dad's brought him
into the ground and and there's just
something about my dad I don't know if
he's The Golden Child or what and so
yeah there is a little doubt there I
mean I'm gonna talk to him all right
what if we do this what if we do this
what if we what if we then take out the
grandfather confrontation piece and the
grandfather who came to you and said I
want you to take this business then the
grandfather just makes he shows you and
proves to you or goes and gets necessary
paperwork done to where uh the the sole
proprietorship that your dad has is is
irrelevant and so so maybe we remove the
confrontation piece cuz he won't do that
part but do you think he'll do the
other yes he will do that well then do
that what we were getting at is like
this is Grandfather needs to take care
of this it's not fair for him to put
that on you to deal with that to tell
Dad he has no part in
this right and by the way I don't think
anybody needs to tell your dad
anything so I'm fine with Granddad going
and showing you okay yep trust me this
is it's in the will I'm sitting with my
lawyer here today you and your H's
husband get the business you know you
don't have to tell your dad anything
keep him out of
it just be ready when he comes running
for his piece of the pie and you have to
get legal involved and it's going to be
messy which is well it shouldn't be
messy if you get all this done with your
grandfather there there's nothing to
there's no mess it's like well the mess
is just dealing with you know that
squeaky wheel of an addict addicted dad
well they can go have a pity party under
the bridge for all I care you got to get
this thing right you know and you get it
right by having Granddad lay it all out
this is my wish this is exactly who's
getting the business and then there's no
argument do you know what I'm saying
right the key is clear communication
upfront in writing and get legal
involved yeah but I'm sorry you have to
deal with this this is not a fun way to
take over a family business
no no but if I'm your grandfather I want
to make sure I leave a legacy and Legacy
means the next person ain't going to
screw it all up and there's no track
record that shows me your dad's going to
be able to handle this and you and your
hubs are going to do great we're excited
for you Nicole just take care of this
don't leave it up to Chance in paper in
writing no worries no messes wow
interesting stuff man all right don't
move because on the other side of this
break we have more of America's
questions this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm Ken
Coleman George camell joins me this hour
the phone number is 8825
8825 5225 before we get to the calls
it's time for our neighborly question of
the day brought to you by of course
neighborly your hub for Home Services if
you need work done on your home or yard
but you don't know where to start or who
to trust neighborly is the answer find
all the help you need at neighborly
decom Ramsey that's neighbor.com
Ramsey today's question comes from Allen
in Georgia should I leave my family's
business although I get a lot of great
experience there I've noticed it
struggles to pay the Tex and owners what
they deserve and cover expenses there's
also lots of debt that hasn't been
addressed I have helped support it with
my own income and hiring feels
impossible due to these challenges I
could find a job making a similar salary
but feel guilty as if I'm running from
the problem on the other hand I don't
feel I have the capability to fix the
problem either thank you for your time
there's your answer Allan because you
don't have the capability to fix the
problem it is no longer your problem and
thus no guilt you got to move on because
this is quickly going to turn into a lot
of um a lot of bitterness a lot of uh
resentment and all of a sudden
Thanksgiving and Christmas is ruined all
because you just went I feel like I have
to stay in the midst of this mess as
opposed to you leave you go do your own
thing uh you you you leave behind the
mess that you can't fix and your your
your mental uh capacity emotional
capacity towards the family that you're
working with that won't fix the problem
all that goes away and you enjoy
Thanksgiving and Christmas I think it's
that simple yeah the only way you should
be involved in a healthy in a family
business if it's a healthy family family
and a healthy business there it is
otherwise you have no moral legal
obligation to just stick this out for
the rest of your life because it's Mom
and Dad's business yeah I'm sorry but if
they're not running it properly you got
to go hey thanks for the opportunity I
learned a lot here I love you guys I'll
always support you but I can't be a part
of this financially or career-wise I
agree yeah that's a hard conversation
I'm not trying to minimize that there's
going to be feelings involved cuz this
is you know Mom and Dad's baby and this
has been in the family for generations
and you're betraying the family but
guess what you can't control how they
react and I'd rather choose guilt over
resentment as some famous psychologist
once
said or lots of people have said and
then maybe it got attributed to somebody
but we we digress we digress thanks for
the question as we get back to the phon
we'll take any of your work rated calls
I'll help you out in that area if you're
feeling stuck you're feeling confused uh
a little bit bored you want to move on
you're trying to figure out how to do
that in the middle of the baby steps we
could talk about that as a part of the
money questions as well and we're going
to get to Tim now and De Moine Iowa Tim
how can we
help hi I've got a question today about
the debt snowball um my wife and I are
on baby step two and for the last eight
months we've been in stor mode um and so
as we've got our debts listed out uh we
kind of just keep staring down that last
um debt which is um just the largest
number and we wonder because we've got a
large lump thumb um if we would be able
like if it would make sense for us to
pay down that largest debt with the lump
thumps that we have smaller debts to
work with and are not kind of staring
down a giant at the end of the snowball
well what's the what's the giant what's
the biggest at what's the smallest at um
so the smallest one is 3,000 uh the
largest one is going to be
14,000 um we've got a total of about
$52,000 in all student loans it's broken
down into nine different um accounts
within those student loans um and so
it's about 2,000 to 6,000 is the rest
and then there's that
$144,000 uh one at the end um and
currently we have uh 19,000 in savings
okay 19k in savings 52 in debt and it's
all student loans yes so you're saying
hey I could throw the 19 at the 14 knock
out the biggest one free up the payment
and continue on the snowball from there
or should I just follow it as it's laid
out smallest to
largest yes how many would you knock out
with you know let's say you have your
thousand emergency fund we throw 18 at
the other debts how many student loans
would you knock
out from smallest um it would be about
four and what would the payments amount
to from those four the minimum
payments about just over $100 a month
between the
four yes I thought it was going to be
more okay yeah so our we were we're on
we uh were defaulted into the income
driven payment um and so total our
minimum payments for all of the student
loans only ends up being about $300 a
month oh gosh well the the good news is
you have way more to throw at that the
bad news is that sucks and if people
follow that plan they would never get
out of debt and it would balloon in
growth so what's your household income
how much are you guys able to throw a
month toward debt on top of minimum
payments um we make about a 100,000 a
year between my wife and I and five jobs
um and then we are doing just about
$22,000 a month right now awesome so at
that rate if you took 18 uh from the 52
that would knock you down to 34 and you
said you could do 2,000 a month yeah man
you're going to knock this out real
quick 17 months according to my records
and I think you're going to even beat
that because it's going to become
addictive you're going to free up more
payments but no I would just follow the
at snowball this is not going to free up
a $700 student loan payment that you can
then use towards the other debts so I'm
going to follow the debt snowball knock
out four of these what are the total you
said you have nine total so you're about
to knock off half of the student
loans that's motivating when you get to
that last one it's just going to be
chipping away you'll freed up some
payments and in six months you'll have
that last one knocked out but I would
just stay the course with this one uh
because it's not going to be that
financially it's not going to make a
financial difference and I think
mentally seeing more debts get knocked
out is better than seeing a big one get
knocked
out okay less to mentally manage yeah
thanks for the call Tim all right let's
go to Birmingham Alabama next Casey's
there Casey how can we
help hey um my husband and I are in baby
step four five and six and we have just
kind of over the years found ourselves
with a little bit of extra cash in a
high old savings account and trying to
figure out best way to utilize that and
I stumbled upon the idea of doing a
mortgage recast and like the idea of
maybe lowering my monthly payments so
that um maybe I can start taking some
more time off of work and being home
with the kids a little bit more more
while they're in the you know teenage
years and wondered if that was a good
idea well the the reasoning behind it is
a very you know I like the motive but
mortgage recasting doesn't actually do
anything uh it's not going to change
your interest rate it will lower your
monthly payment but it also causes you
to be less motivated to continue paying
down the principal and so it'll just
take longer to pay down at that
point yeah right but it does give me the
option to you know if I do have certain
time when I'm taking more time off I've
done a big chunk of money towards that
to where it's you know I am paying it
down quicker we're usually paying about
3,000 extra a month already on it and I
would keep doing that it would just
allow me to do that without that money
sitting in the high yield savings
account but if your income doesn't
change and your expenses don't really
change because you're still throwing the
3,000 a month then we haven't really
solved any problem could you just stay
home yeah while continuing on as you
have
been no definitely not my income is a
little bit higher in the f
right but I think we're what we're
getting at here Casey is you're you're
really trying the problem you're trying
to solve is you'd like to spend more
time with the
kids so you're not accomplishing
anything with a mortgage recast in your
mind you're going well it gives me more
time with the kids and I think we can
figure out more time with the kids
without doing the
recast so what has to be true so let's
just assume that we were going forward
with the recast okay which we're not we
don't think you should do that doesn't
really accomplish anything for you
financially so really we want to figure
out with our time and with the fam is
what we're trying to solve for so how
much time would you want to spend with
the kids extra time where you're not in
the traditional workplace um just being
home in the afternoons when they get
home from school but give me I mean
let's talk real hours here what are we
talking about how many hours prob an
extra nine hours a week off all right
nine hours a week so what I would be
doing is I'd be thinking how do we find
nine hours a week how do you make the
same money you're making making are
pretty darn
close and so we don't affect our income
and all of our financial goals cuz you
guys are killing it by the way so how
can I do that and find nine hours with
the kids what is it a job change is it a
shift change because you're so valuable
I think that's what you're trying to
solve for don't you think George how do
we find that or 9 hours or 7 hours or
six hours that's a very different
problem I just don't think refinancing
you're doing the recast actually solves
anything here it might mean you have too
much house it gets you the 9 hours but
it hurts you in other ways let's get to
the root of the problem before just
moving around the dead a little bit Yeah
I think that's the way to go and I love
your heart for that I think it's a good
idea and I think you can do it I think
you got to get creative and you have to
look specifically in that area thanks
for the call Casey this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to y
refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell joins me
this hour by the way it's camel with a K
want to make sure you get that right
thank you for that Ken it's not the
animal but it is pronounced as such
that's right I like that and uh very
easy to remember we got a great studio
audience with Lobby camel and Coleman we
sound like the worst Law Firm ever we're
like the law firm you know like in Rain
Maker you know we're just trying to win
the first case that's all it takes by
the way do you know that movie The Rain
Maker it's been a while I was probably a
toddler but you know I mentioned it on
the show yesterday with Rachel Cruz
never heard of it your references are
she acted like I was a grandpa they're a
bit dated we can all admit that does
that mean that I'm dated no you're
Classic that's how I look at you oh
Timeless look at how he spins folks
nobody George should run for Congress
that was just absolutely effortless
there didn't sprain an ankle at all well
done my friend as always shall we help
Melissa I hope so all right Melissa how
can we
help
hello hello guys um thank you I'm so
grateful to get your advice today all
right well let's see if it's any good we
don't know
yet so I am new to the Ramy show um I've
been binge watching for about two months
and what I'm realizing well first of all
we're on baby step number two and what
I'm realizing as I listen to you guys is
that I haven't we haven't been putting
nearly enough into our
401ks and so I'm trying to concentrate
on baby number two but I'm nervous for
the advice of stopping my investing
because I feel like I'm 46 years old and
I feel like I'm already behind and so it
makes me nervous that I'm going to be in
trouble at retirement well your nerves
are Justified but there's a reason why
we do it George absolutely well tell us
about your nest egg what's in there now
between the the
household um so I have um
134,000 in my
401k um I also have an IRA from a
previous job and that's got 104,000 in
it but I'm not adding to that one so
it's just you know sitting there
hopefully growing okay and then my
husband has about 880,000 in his um his
401k okay so that's not
nothing I mean you could be working
nothing but it's not it's not enough
it's retirement I don't think I know
well it's not right now but compound
growth is going to work its magic over
the next 15 to 20 years of your careers
and by the way if you're listening to
this show we're going to up your
investing and there's going to be
catchup contributions and you're going
to start to make Leaps and Bounds in the
investing side that's what I'm nervous
about but first we go to we got to eat
our vegetables and that's getting out of
debt yes so how much debt do you
have um Counting the mortgage uh
226,000 take out the mortgage let's
focus on baby step two what's the
Consumer
Debt um so if you have a calculator
226,000
minus um
180,000 okay so you got 46 in Consumer
Debt what does that make up of what's in
there um we have two
cars um and and then two credit cards
one of the credit cards is very small
I'll be paying that off by January okay
and what's the household
income um my husband and I together um
we make about uh 210,000 a year after
taxes and insurance and all that tax
bring home about 10,000 a month no no no
no 210 a year is the salary we bring
home about 10,000 a month after taxes
and insurance and 41k Investments and
all that stuff okay and how much are you
currently investing
what percentage I invest I invest um 6%
at my job and then my employer matches
4% and then my husband is he's only
investing 4% at his job okay so here's
the encouragement if you follow this
plan we're going to get you out of this
muck and Meer and cycle of investing
measly percentages like four and six%
and we're going to like triple that you
see what that does if both of you get up
to 15% of that amazing income that's
going to be thousands of dollars more a
year you're investing that are going to
be working for you with compound
growth okay so you're not going to fall
behind 15% of each of our incomes not
the how it's not just 15% of that think
about it this way 15% of your income
plus 15% of his income becomes 15% of
your household
income so it's the same amount okay you
know $100,000 15% is 15 grand so if each
of you make 50 you invest 15% it's still
going to add up to that 15 grand I'm
curious what kind of debt you have on
the car uh how much do you have any
equity in those cars at
all um yeah quite a bit I think um I
have one car that um we owe about 15,000
and it's KY Blue Book is showing about
24,000 for um private party sale um the
other car we probably owe exactly what
it's worth about 13,000 all right here's
a crazy idea I don't know if George
agrees with don't get rid of my cars
don't get rid of my cars you don't have
to you don't have to I mean you guys
make enough income to where you can pay
this off but you you approach this with
the idea you're brand new to us right
you've been binge watching videos and
you're nervous about uh pausing the
retirement savings right yes you're
nervous about it yes so if you want to
speed it up you sell the cars you don't
have to you guys make enough money where
you can pay those cars off but if you
wanted to speed up the timeline I don't
think it's too aggressive to say uh I
sell I sell sell the cars or at least
sell one of them the one that I've got a
lot of equity in and you said you got
about 15,000 of equity in it I think you
said something like that um you know
that's about 10,000 in the one car yeah
oh 10,000 one but I mean there's a lot
of decent cars out there for
$10,000 and you get a nice car nice
$110,000 car boom that car payment is
gone that money goes towards paying
everything else off that is the snowball
as you understand it yes you understand
how we we we we move those payments I'm
saying you could speed this time line up
thus speeding up the amount of time that
you're pausing Am I Wrong George in
saying
that I still pause investing on top of
that but here's the thing because she
was so against selling the car that
tells me all right well then you're
backed into the corner of having to
pause investing if you want to get out
of debt here's the good news Melissa you
PA's investing making 210 all being
thrown at the debt every single piece of
margin you have you're gone in 6 months
you got rid of this debt and now we
upped our investing and can I share some
numbers I've been crunching them over
here while Ken was babbling on oh you
ready for this
that's okay so you have 318,000 in your
nest egg 318 right you're 46 you have
318 total if you invested nothing else
zero dollars for the rest of your life
and you had an average annual return of
10% which is the average we've seen with
the S&P 500 you guys would have $1.5
million of 62 that's good
right 1.5 million ain't bad I mean it's
it's wonderful I just don't know if it's
enough to well how about this meliss 20
years after retir we're not going to do
zero dollar in investing going to happen
is 6 months from now we take 15% of 210
well now we're cooking with gas that's
2625 a month you're throwing to
Investments now at 62 you have $2.8
million is that better okay that that
sounds much better you just added 1.3
million by following the Ramsey plan and
all I'm asking you to do is for six
months just trust us and bring investing
down to zero six months okay do you
trust me I feel like Aladdin right
now I mean George I totally trust you
and that's if by the way I wouldn't
trust you after two months that's if
your income never goes up and you guys
just
totally hang hang up the hat at 62 yeah
okay and so the chances are when you get
to 62 you're going to have even more
money than that or we could still be
playing this game you could be calling
the show Ken's going to be ancient by
then still and by the way still babbling
and still babbling but still very
fashionable and we'll be having the same
conversation of you going I'm worried
about pausing investing we've investing
4% we still have the debt I don't
Melissa this is George just laid out the
long game for you you're playing the
long game investing for retirement is
the long game right okay yes yes so you
have to approach it that way and so this
is a shortterm pause after I finish baby
step then I go 15% on I know it's baby
step two you got you're still in baby
step two once you finish the baby step
two you're going to put three to six
months emergency fund in the bank and
that's your emergency fund now we pick
back up with the with the 15% and that
may feel an eons away we're really
talking about 12 months S one of them
cars maybe both of them that's really
hates your cars Melissa I don't hate
your cars I just know that listen I'm
also I'm also cash flowing uh my son's
college so money is super tight so it's
just kind of I get it totally but guess
what saves you money selling the cars
car crazy is later on down the line you
can you can buy more cars you can real
quick Melissa what is your combined car
payments between two both cars
uh
780 oh give me the tumbs James where's
my tumbs $700 a month you said times are
tight sell the cars Ken's always
jonesing for those Tums well when I hear
$700 car payment what else am I supposed
to have
Macks that could do the
trick milk of magnesia gosh what is the
product Pepto I don't know we'll figure
it out during the commercial break and
let you know when we come back this is
this is the ramsy
[Music]
shot
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by George camel the phone
number for you to jump in it's 8825 5225
that's
5225 and George and I were talking
during the break and and when you when
you sit in uh for a legend an icon Dave
Ramsey as the Ramsey personalities do uh
on a regular basis and we take your
calls on money and we've all taught the
classes you know I'm not I'm not a a a
money focused personality obviously I'm
in the work space um but we have George
we've got Rachel and we've got Jade all
in the money space and there's just so
much to be learned so much to talk about
from a money standpoint and George's new
book is coming out in in January release
date of January January 16th January
16th and the book is I'm holding it in
my hand right here if you're watching
Breaking Free from broke and and I I
don't want our audience and I don't want
anybody else to go oh this is just going
to be watered down Total Money Makeover
cuz it's not it's watered up baby it's
not watered up it's spiked up I dare say
there's some Tabasco in this there's
some George camel snark in this how is
this book different and why should
people order this book pre-order this
book now well if you've been following
my story and my path and the stuff I've
done here you know we did borrowed
future podcast find print and so this is
investigative it's eye openening I
really want to rile up an entire
generation to go yeah we were sold this
Primrose path and we fell for it and I'm
sick of it and I want to build wealth in
spite of what the heck is happening in
this world and so the first two-thirds
of the book Canen I show you how the
system this financial industrial complex
is designed to keep you broke all the
lies and myths that we were sold and
then I show you how it's not all your
fault but it's your responsibility to
break free from those lies and to take
in the truth bust those myths deprogram
and unplug from The Matrix and it's how
I went from broke to millionaire and I
it's got so much research so much humor
and I think everyone's going to love it
so it's on pre-sale now what do they get
when they pre-order now and what is the
cost what do they get in the it's 20
bucks for the hard copy and then we are
going to also send you a 100 bucks worth
of bonus items the ebook we're doing an
enhanced audio book access to exclusive
online event and Q&A you get three
months of every dollar premium along
with that and access to my smart
conference talk called show me the money
so we're packing it all in there and a
fun little poster on 21 interesting
facts about camels you didn't know that
that might be a bonus item we need to
include Ken yeah that's gonna we'll
Workshop that one yeah I should point
out folks I am joking I've said things
on the show before that I was convinced
we completely sarcastic and people
believed it so sometimes it's in your
favor there is no camel poster facts
about camels in the pre-order you can
Google that though for yourself but but
I'm sure somebody's done that somebody
got to that one before we did uh ramsy
solutions.com to pre-order Breaking Free
from broke it's a really good book and
George's got a baby girl now and he
needs to feed her so at college fund Ken
we're starting to fund that 529 529 here
we go Jacob in Greenville South Carolina
is up next Jacob how can we
help uh hey good afternoon guys uh just
want to start by saying I big fan of the
rain maker
so thank you somebody who appreciates a
good movie and a good book by the way by
John gome how can we help
absolutely um so uh I am I'm an attorney
I'm currently self-employed I'm able to
work from home which is a
blessing um uh because I'm an attorney I
had to I guess I didn't have to but I
decided to take out student loans in
order to pay for that and uh right now
they're at about 150
,000 um I'm on a incom driven uh
repayment plan currently uh which is
about 517 a month um I have two kids two
young kids um my wife's able to uh stay
at home with them which is great um but
I guess um I'm trying to figure out how
to get out from under this because it's
just been a burden laying on me for how
long have you had
these uh since I started started at Law
School in
2013 uh I'm sorry uh
2010 and I've graduated in 2013 so I've
been paying them and on uh since then
yeah for I'm guessing the balance hasn't
moved much because of these income
driven repayment plans and the interest
keeps causing the balance to grow as you
pay it down so what was the original
balance uh I I don't even remember it
was it was close to probably a
100 yeah it was about 30 some a year
where I went I went instate but it was
still uh expensive well what's your
income so uh right now uh it's 100 uh on
the nose it's like 83 33 Okay per month
and then since I'm self-employed I pay
uh you know quarterly estimated taxes on
that on that that
um uh correct okay so about 25 it's
about 2500 I pay per a quarter
what my accountant set up for me cool so
there's a few steps I want you to take
to not just feel overwhelmed and
burdened by this and number one is to
make a written budget and I'm going to
gift you one year of every dollar
premium so that you can map out this
plan of your 100,000 income your
expenses and what you're going to do is
see if there's margin after you list out
all of your expenses have it mirror your
actual reality of your bills and then we
can make a plan cuz right now I would
love for you to be debt free in 2 years
how would you like
that that would be unbelievable well
let's look at the math that's 75 grand a
year getting thrown at these loans so
now we know okay I need to throw 75
grand I only make a 100 and I got to pay
bills first so what do we need to do to
find that Gap well partially we might
need to cut expenses partially we need
to increase our income is your wife able
to do any kind of work to bring in some
income and you work overtime and do some
more work as well
yeah so I am doing uh some other side
work uh that
makes about
1,800 bi-weekly or so but it's not it's
temporary work so it's not it kind of
comes and goes but okay um and what does
it look like to increase your salary in
in the law
field how do we get to you making not
150 200
250 yeah I I would have to either try of
find a different like Network to go
through with what I do okay um or or go
to my current uh who I'm kind of working
for right now and kind of say Hey you
know I'd like that increase but I'm not
at that point yet I want to get at least
another year in with them before I kind
of go to them about well I want Ken to
walk you through the steps to take to go
from 100,000 salary as an attorney to
$200,000 cuz I think it's very much
possible and I don't want you to feel
like well that might be years and years
from now yeah what kind of law practice
are you in what excuse me specialty
um so believe it or not I actually uh
represent uh uh consumers who are have
been sued by
creditors okay and are you working for a
firm or are you
independent uh so I'm basically I work I
help out I represent uh people who are
in like debt settlement uh
companies so if they get sued I'm part
of their
program okay but again representation
yeah are are you so are you're like a
contractor like a lawyer who's
contracted out the multiple
companies correct all right so what's
the ladder look like in in that type of
law do you see Financial growth I mean
is that something where you can really
grow your
income um yeah that's where I'm not I'm
not really sure that it's something I
can really grow it much more than where
I am the answer let's go ahead and round
up and say the answer is no so you have
a law degree and and what other types of
law Specialties or areas can you focus
on right now what could you quickly move
into um it would be tough because I I'm
barred in a different state than where I
live so I would have
to find something that's remote or
something
that is there a position where let's say
it was wasn't remote where you could
double your
income if you work for a big firm
um it's I mean if if I were able to get
like inhouse counil at a company where
they don't it doesn't matter where your
bar yeah that would be something Jacob
start to do some homework Jacob I must
tell you please don't take WR way I have
a point well I you're just a little
too well laadle bro is that the word you
got a law
degree if you're barred in one state fix
it go find a path a ladder where that
law degreee is bringing in 350 450 550
650 this is not difficult stuff my
friend this is intentional action and
you need to take control cuz that solves
a lot of your problem right there thank
you for the call George Campell good
hour thanks to James Childs and the guys
in the booth thank you America this is
the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
m live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey Show it's
where we help you win in your life by
helping you win with your money in your
work and in your relationships I'm Kim
Coleman George camel joins me the phone
number is 88255 225 that's tollfree
America
8825 5225 Grand Rapids Michigan is where
we start this hour Kate is there on the
line Kate how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call how
are you doing well we're having a blast
what can we help you
with um I feel like I'm a lost cause and
I'm possibly stuck where I'm at and what
I'm doing well let me start by saying
number one you are not a lost cause and
you are not stuck my guess is you've
choosen to stay put because of fear and
doubt how about
that well I've been let down a lot when
um I'll bet I was debt free at one point
yeah a few times actually 100% like my
phone or not my phone hello sorry my car
my student loan and everything credit
cards were all paid off I'm get to go
had cash to my name and I tried to get a
house and all I heard was no and no and
no and I'm a single
parent of two kids and
it's extremely hard to
um get out of the subsidized housing
I've been in for 10 years about and I'm
tired of having to tell them when I get
more money when I don't get more money
and just the fluctuation the paperwork
and it's already Harden two kids yeah on
my own and no dad's to help so I'm sorry
well George and I are gonna help we're
gonna help I only work parttime as a
parpro in a school for 16 an
hour and I feel like I really want to
work full-time
I know
you and I really want to you know bust
it out and break free of this feel like
a cell in my heart and in my home I want
to get somewhere and I feel like I'm
just no one knows anything in my family
about money and I feel like all I knew
was saving and debt and I never knew
about all this other stuff until I
watched Dave
the screw to people well listen which is
nice because like I need that kick in
the pants too yeah well let me tell you
what you need you need some confidence
because I I believe that you have what
it takes to repeat the process of
getting out of debt you've done it
before so I know you can do it again I
also know that you're you're up against
it right now because you're just simply
not bringing enough
income no and I mean if you were
bringing in more income living now but
I'm afraid if I get out here how am I
going to make it well so
income okay income and a budget all
right so let's talk about the income
piece for a second all right so what
would you need to make financially to be
able to get out of subsidized housing
and get a decent place to rent for you
and the kiddos what's that
number
oh I honestly don't know okay what's
keeping you what keep is so low right
now it's like 107 for my rent
but that's feasible but a regular rent
around here it's anywhere between 1,200
and 1500 I
may Kate Kate all right you got to
listen now okay you're making a lot of
excuses and I know you've been through a
lot we can't make any more excuses so
you said you need somebody to kind of
give you a little kick in the pants and
I'm going to do that as gently as I can
George is a lot nicer than I am but I'm
going to be nice I'm good cop he's back
okay no but listen we got a number now
let's take the highest number just
because it's going to help us George and
I are going to do this this together
okay now okay George is going to help
out on the budgeting and all that kind
of stuff a second but I want to get this
income Factor figured out all right so
let's say $1,500 a month is something
that that gets us a nice place to live
and oh my gosh how happy would you be if
you could easily afford a 12 to $1,500
apartment how happy would you be Kate
tell
me I honestly don't want to be in any
apartment anymore though okay where do
you want where do you want to be Kate
stop hold on big Le getting a house Kate
we got to take a baby step for now Kate
Kate you've never played basketball and
you want a dunk it doesn't work that
way stop that right now stop
that okay an apartment that is not
government subsidized housing is the
next goal yes or
no you better say yes yes you're only
working okay here's the deal Kate you're
only working part-time as a parpro in a
school making $16 an hour you are not
making enough money you are a mama bear
who has gotten put in a tough situation
because of dead beat dads these guys if
they were in this studio right now i'
I'd get after them with a whiffle ball
bat CU I couldn't hurt them bad enough
to really put them in the hospital but
I'd sting them good they're jerks
they're loow lives they're lazy they're
punks all the words that I can say on
the air and I understand that and it
sucks but you're the mama bear and you
got to take care of those kiddos and you
are worth way more than $16 an hour so
you got to go work at Walmart or Kroger
or somewhere or Target where they're
paying a lot more than $16 an hour
they're paying healthare benefits they
will even pay for your college education
Walmart has made this a national program
Kate I'm giving you one
idea I just got out of Walmart I don't
care go back
no $20 it was 14 and that was still
parttime and I had to be there one day
weekend and I have no sitter to watch
you got to find somebody you got to find
an old lady who goes to a church that
you go to you've got to stop making
excuses and you've got to start making
things happen so income is is what you
have got to do you have got to make more
money if it's two jobs three jobs and we
find somebody to watch the kiddos you
can find a way
and then George what do she got to do
with that money well we're going to put
it to use in our budget Kate and I'm
going to throw some things at you we're
going to gift you some stuff to help you
take that right Next Step because we
only have a minute here on the air but
how much debt do you
have I am wiling my last um or I'm
plastic surgery my last discovery card
good at about
$4,900 okay so once the $4,900 credit
card bill is gone you're completely debt
free completely yet again do you have
with gambling and drinking I have two
addictions as well been are you seeking
counseling and help for that yes I am
okay good so we're going to get you on
some good footing on that side on top of
getting you out of debt do you have any
money in the
bank uh I keep that very minuscule so
basically no just enough for my bills so
I don't go and use my debit card for
purchases I don't need to okay that's
good well what I'm going to do is I'm
going to set you up with one of our
ramsy financial coaches on our team and
I'm going to gift that session to you so
they can take some time pour into the
details and walk you through this on top
of that I'm going to gift you one year
of every dollar premium I'm going to
gift you Financial Peace University
watch all of those nine lessons begin to
make a budget even if you don't have a
lot of income make the budget income
then your expenses then we know what the
Gap is then we can see what we need to
do to get out of this debt to build the
emergency fund get on our feet increase
our income like Ken said and get get out
of this cycle we believe you can do it
there's nothing that a mama bear
wouldn't do for a kiddos and you're
going to have to choose those kiddos
right now and you're going to have to
work like you've never worked before in
your life is it going to be really hard
yes is it doable yes are you the only
single mom to ever have to do it no you
got to choose today's the day to choose
your babies and their future this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramy show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by George camel 88255
2258 825 5225 when you were growing up
and you were in elementary school and
your name was said in front of the class
did you ever think anybody'd say it the
way I just said that no you hit that in
a beautiful way with a lot of punch and
Gusto that was not said by my third
grade teacher yeah I just want to make
sure that you paid attention to that
thank you I appreciate the affirmation
all right very good it made me feel good
if nothing else all right Russell's up
next in Phoenix Arizona Russell how can
we
help oh yes so thanks for taking my call
how you guys doing uh we're having a
blast what's
up yeah
so uh my question is my wife and I just
recently um got on board with starting
the baby steps and uh so we got our we
just got you know every dollar budget
and created the budget so this can be
probably the first real month of
budgeting and doing that kind of stuff
on both of us together and so by the end
of this month we should be doing baby
step one of getting our $1 th so I'm
trying to prepare all our debts for the
debt snowball for baby step
2 and the question I have for you guys
is we are in quite a bit of debt um
almost $200,000 in Consumer
Debt and I have three car loans that we
are upside down all three and that the
main question I'm calling about is I'm
trying to make the plan for how to get
rid of at least two of these cars but at
this point I don't have the extra to
cover the the what I'm under on them and
and and because of my credit and my you
know being so low I'm not able to get a
personal loan for them so i' would have
to save up the the the extra so that's
where the kind of the meat of the
question is is so I know I want to get
rid of at least two of these cars I know
how much I would need to save in my debt
snowball should I put the amount I need
to save further up in the debt snowball
like if I need $5,000 to pay off one of
the cars so I put that five grand in
that order because the car I would owe
15,000 I would need five in order to
sell it okay so that's kind of my
question and should I put you're
basically saying should I just kind of
pause my debt snowball make minimum
payments while stacking up the cash
needed to get out from to this
thing well either that or just pretend
those cars are 5,000 and do my that
snowball but instead of my car being at
15,000 in the de snowball I put my car
at 5,000 in the de
snowball I think saving up as much cash
quickly and getting out of this thing is
going to be your best bet to gain some
traction so tell me what are these cars
how How far underwater what do these
loans add up to on these cars yes okay
so this uh for so all three
so the smallest one is 15,000 okay then
the next one is 20
27,000 and then the biggest one is
49,000 okay go through those again 15
what is that car worth okay so the 15 is
worth the highest I could probably sell
for on um personal sale is about 10
grand that's if I can get like the max
of it okay then the next one
one is about
23 uh maybe 22 23,000 mhm and the
biggest one unfortunately I bought in
the height of car prices during the
pandemic and that's only worth about 35
to
37,000 okay all right what are the total
payments on between these three
loans uh yeah so smallest is
424 O then
and then 1,33 oh boy where are the TS
over
$2,000 in car payments wow man no wonder
you can't breathe and that's not even
all of your debt we still got no what's
the other
debt yeah so the other debt is um
student loans between my wife and I
maybe about 25 to 30,000 I have the
numbers but not in front of me so I
don't remember exactly but so about 2530
for students
loans uh active credit cards maybe about
five and then I have a credit card in
collections for about
nine okay and that's
everything that doesn't feel like it
adds up to
200 yeah I wish I my every dollar I just
did it all into every dollar and uh
seems like there's a big there's a
gaping hole here where you got some
other debt but so you only need you said
thought you thought about oh solar loan
sorry I have a solar loan for about like
about 30 about 40,000 there we go oh boy
okay oh boy yeah sorry yeah man first of
all is there a spending addiction here
as to how you got into you kept buying
all these cars you couldn't afford and
did you roll negative equity into the
next one and the next
one so um that was part of it a part of
it was rolling negative equity into the
new cars the other part of it is
a couple years back you know my wife and
I were in a bad spot in our marriage and
she was kind of desperate to find
something to make her happy and she
bought a third car so there was
relationship issues which caused
spending plus just dumb rolling negative
equity into some other vehicles so it
was it was a mixture of both and for the
last year I've been trying to work with
my wife to try to get back on track and
so finally this last month we both
agreed it was harder to convince her but
she finally got on board that's why I'm
calling now is now I'm not okay you're
on both on board we're ready what's the
household
income household
income let's see net bringing home is
about uh right under 10 grand 10 grand a
month net yes oh a month okay so in your
budget how much margin is left after
making all your minimum payments all
$2,000 of car loans plus all the other
debt is there anything
left yeah so as we just did the we just
did the budget and for like this
month we had a couple extra things to do
this month like getting tires for one of
the cars but besides that our normal
what we have left to throw a debt is
between around eight to uh 800 to ,000 a
month if we cut back on on what the need
will cut back on you know spend eating
out that kind of thing there's about
$800 to $1,000 a month okay so I I want
to get to something really quick George
he said he he was worried that he
couldn't sell the cars because he
couldn't get a personal loan but and it
doesn't seem like he's got bad credit
you're making payments on all these
things so you probably have a you know
you could go get the uh sell all three
cars and then just consolidate the
difference into one loan from like a
local credit yeah where do you have all
these loans through is it through one
place multiple
places yeah the car loans are multiple
so you know you got Kia finance and you
got Ally and then you have another one
for the third one I did already try
because I was already thinking about how
to do this and I did try already to get
a personal loan you need to walk in
there and ask for the manager and say
listen you guys have a bad loan on your
hands and here's what I'm asking you to
do cover the difference and allow me to
take that on as a personal loan because
right now you have a loan out for 15K
and the car is only worth
10 okay and so you need to be real clear
with them that this thing's about to get
repoed or we could solve this if they're
willing to give you the difference so
that you can get out from under
it you and your wife need to show up
with the manager and talk through the
situation and explain exactly what's
going on with these numbers and say
listen we want to get out of this thing
we want to give back this money we need
to get these personal loans done in
order to crawl out from under these
underwater
cars but outside of that the only other
way is to save up the difference and
knock them out one by one and that to me
is going to be your A1 going forward
let's save up four grand let's get out
from the 27 let's save up another five
grand let's get out from the 15 and so
as you do that you're going to free up
$2,000 worth of payments that we can use
to attack the other de I think you're
working two and three jobs too we need
to up the income yeah you got to take
what's the $800 you can throw towards
debt and you've got to double that you
guys are selling everything man working
like crazy no more cards no debt is off
the table we're going to have to find
out another way to do it no more car
loans no more credit cards no more solar
loans no more Liv in Lita Loca we had
our fun and it about destroyed our
marriage let's try something different
so hang on the line I'm going to send
you fin Peace University and I'm going
to send you every doll premium since
you're already using every dollar this
will upgrade you you can track
transactions use paycheck planning all
kinds of features but man we hope you
get out of this and I hope it's a
beautiful Redemption story ah here
there's the Tums and James brought in
the Tums cuz Ken's an acid anytime I see
more than $1,000 car payment 2,000 in
car payments alone this is a fresh jar
I'm going to have to open this up on the
commercial oh there it is by the way
special bonus points if you can tell me
who's saying live in Lita Loca Ricky
Martin leather pants final answer Ricky
Martin and Tums for the win this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm Ken
Coleman George Campell joins me the
phone number for you to jump in Isle
88255 225 but before we take more calls
in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions
standing on the de free stage Jackson
and Hannah from the Lincoln Nebraska
area welcome you two hey how you doing
all right you guys are here I guess to
do a debt free SCP I presume yes awesome
awesome awesome all right let's get the
numbers here how much debt did you pay
off $
26,136 all right
26,000 and how long did that take eight
months eight months okay what was your
range of income during that time it was
77,000 and at the end it was 81,000 nice
and what do you guys do for a living I'm
a bank teller okay and I am an engine
overhaul technician for airplane engines
waa we we thank you for your service my
friend thank you yeah you want that guy
to be you want him to be fresh on the
job absolutely paying attention all
right very good okay so um eight months
ago you guys are a young couple I think
that's fair to say how long you been
married two years okay so what happened
eight months ago where these Newly Weds
decide uh let's get out of debt so it
was uh we got married in 2021 uhhuh and
then a couple months later we decided to
buy a house in another state in Kansas
and so after we moved there I was still
working in Lincoln Nebraska and it was
just getting really hard we were using
credit cards uh I owed money on my truck
uh I owed money to family members
because we borrowed money from them to
pay for the down payment for the house
because we were broken we couldn't
afford it sure and so several months
passed by and I buy a camper so I can
stay up in Nebraska in the camper cuz
it's cheaper I got a loan for that and
when I went to go pay the tax taxes for
registering it we didn't have any money
and I just I kind of broke down because
I had to put it on a credit card in
order to even pay the taxes for it and I
decided then like something needs to
change and luckily we were able to sell
the camper and that's why it's not
included in the debt okay and I was just
like I got to get out we I got to get
out of this and I was mainly doing the
finances so I was kind of taking it on
by myself so did Hannah know about the
stress that was happening I really
didn't have any clue um in my family my
dad always handled all the finances and
my mom kind of really didn't know what
was going on just knew that everything
was fine and you were following the same
footsteps it seems yeah so when we got
married that was kind of like oh like
he's going to take care of everything
and it's going to be fine so you think
hey our life is fine yeah until this is
all going very well yeah until one day
he comes to me and is like hey our
credit card bill is $5,000 and there's
no way we can pay for it and then it was
kind of like oh no we need to do
something now to get ourselves out of
this wow so what what made up that 26k
what kind of debt was that so it was a
truck loan it was money from family uh
for the down payment for the house it
was like I owed money on my phone from
my cell phone carrier uh different
credit cards just kind of the works you
know all the normal stuff noral of
payments all right so I want to go back
to that moment okay you find out that
you guys are in debt $5,000 specifically
on the credit card and you don't think
you can pay it what was the conversation
what what' you guys do next so I
contacted my sister shout out to you
Emily um because I was going to do the
0% intro balance transfer to the new
card and she had done that before on on
one of her cards and so I was going to
try that and she mentioned to me this
debt snowball and I was like well what
is that um you know paying the highest
interest first would make more sense
right uh so then she said it was from
Dave Ramsey and I was like oh Dave
Ramsey is just that rich snob who tells
people to pay for things with cash cuz
he's so I wish he was here to hear that
yeah he would love that he loves that
I'm kind of glad he wasn't here for this
one cuz
all no trust me he actually loves that
he it's weird but then that night I was
just sitting there and I was thinking
you know what maybe we should try this
maybe we should try this so at work I
started listening to the podcast on
Spotify and I started doing the dead
snowball and then I'd come home and I
talk to her about it and it just you
know we just went game on from that
moment you and hey our plan hasn't been
working let's listen to this Rich snob
appar he's helped some people exactly
that's incredible what was one of the
big sacrifices you guys made as a young
couple trying to start out your life
trying to live this lifestyle what do
you have to cut out um well I love
coffee I love going to you know all the
coffee shops and stuff and so you know
that was like a big like okay we really
need to cut out everything that's not
necessary and coffee is not necessary
did you go uncaffeinated or did you just
make it at home brewed coffee at home
yeah less exciting did did you go cheap
coffee oh yeah for sure store brand
like nothing makes you want to get out
of debt like drinking generic brand
coffee made at home you're like I'm
ready to get back to the
lattes we we got rid of the uh
subscriptions as well like Netflix
Amazon and we actually were spending
Less on Amazon after we got rid of prime
there thank you for proving I always
tell people listen I know Prime hurts to
cut but you're going to also spend less
on top of saving on the subscription it
works yeah wow I'm proud of you guys
that's a lot of sacrifice to make as a
young couple who you know loves
convenience and caffeine yeah yeah
that's impressive now what was your
support system through this who who
rather was your support system yeah our
our support system was pretty much both
of our families and all pretty much all
of our friends and even though they
might not understand everything that
we're doing they're always like go you
know go for it you guys are doing
awesome uh you know congratulations on
being debt free and everything and so we
got really lucky and both of our family
and some of my family members have
started this journey as well and I got
them going on this too incred what led
to the increase in income I'm always
fascinated by this stat it's almost a
guarantee that when we have a debt-free
couple or a person up there that their
income always increases I'm curious what
you guys did to see that PMP I got a
second job that I absolutely hated
working in retail that's even better
yeah can you tell us the name of the
retailer or is it George I'm just
curious what you know you are curious
I'm a man of retail I used to work a lot
of retail so I didn't hate the company I
just hated you know I had already was
working 40 hours at my fulltime
and it was always like right after my
job at 5 5 to 9 so it was kind of like
my my day was really long that's right
yeah was it worth it all oh yeah for
sure the little bit of extra money that
I was able to to contribute towards our
overall income just made me feel really
good and he was putting in a lot of
extra overtime hours luckily he was able
to oh good have that flexibility with
his job at the time so well look let me
tell you something eight
months okay that's incredible wasn't a
life sentence I mean you guys knocked us
out in eight months I understand it was
26,000 but still eight months you guys
got after it and now you're on the other
side of it so what would you say to
maybe some other young couples that are
early on in their marriage and they're
staring at some debt what's the key to
getting out of debt from your journey
what would you say be on board with one
another I think we were really lucky
that we were both like okay let's do
this right away uh we didn't have to
convince the other one um and kind of
just that Unity of having the the goal
at the end of the finish line and being
able to just you know do the work that
it's going to take because it's going to
be hard uh but it's 100% worth it and
sacrifice you need to sacrifice
sacrifice your time to work more to make
extra money sacrifice your subscription
sacrifice eating out like it is worth it
to go through this and being on the
other side of it it is you know
incredibly worth it to be debt free well
this freedom on the other side a lot of
people think come on man Jackson and and
I YOLO I got to enjoy my life I got to
eat out and here you are with such
freedom on the other side with so many
options with so much margin to give save
spend like no one else what's your next
Big Goal uh so you know we're investing
15% we have our our emergency fund um
another thing um you know our starter
went out a couple weeks ago and we
didn't even worry about it because you
know we have an emergency fund and we
able to just fit that in the budget um
but the next big thing definitely is
Cash flowing my flight school and that's
what I'm doing right now so we're able
to do that because we're debt free and
did you say flight school flight school
awesome yeah now that's expensive very
expensive I want people to hear this
what is flight school going to set you
back uh like
$100,000 okay I wanted people to hear
this this young man who goes all right
we're going to cash flow this absolutely
because a lot of people would reckon
themselves into well I reckon it's worth
it if I take on the loan for that good
for you and uh you know what it's like
to wait on something and you're going to
get there you're still young how long do
you anticipate it's going to take you to
save and finish probably five years or
more honestly yeah but it's going to be
worth it when you're up there in the
friendly skies get free baby hey we've
got the living give box for you and
we'll make sure to get that to you with
all the books and FPU and all that good
stuff you can give away Total Money
Makeover to someone and then you're on
your way to being a baby step
millionaire great young couple here we
go let's get to it Jackson and Hannah
the Lincoln Nebraska area paid off
$226,000 in 8 months making 77 up to
$81,000 let's hear your debt free scream
Eric I know you're watching this pay off
your alone all right ready 3 2
1 watch out wow that was El electric
yeah because he shouted out somebody
hopefully you didn't have your volume up
too high but that'll put some pep in
your step to get out of De America love
it this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman George camel joins me
and we're got to get to a couple things
here George and then we've got a fun
announcement to make but first our
scripture of the day 1 Corinthians 15 58
therefore my dear brothers and sisters
stand firm let nothing move you always
give yourselves fully to the work of the
Lord because you know that your labor in
the Lord is not in vain and uh not sure
how we got this quote not sure who
picked this one but it's from Aussie
Osborne all right you've got to try and
take things to the next level or you'll
just get stuck in a rut I'm not going to
lie that quote was from a day that we
thought to was going to be on that
explains that one that makes sense only
delone would appreciate that quote I'm
not even sure what any of that means but
thank you Azie I just think all AB board
there it is Ken I want to call out real
quick oh yeah big news by the way
Veterans Day yeah it's coming up and in
honor of Veterans Day we are giving away
Financial Peace University to 10,000
veterans totally free to honor them now
through Monday November 13th uh so make
sure if you got a veteran in your life
most of us do they want to take FPU for
free them go to ramsy solutions.com
veterans and fill out a real simple form
we appreciate them so much we honor them
and I hope you all enjoy the holiday as
we remember yeah so much sacrifice all
over the country happening daily we get
the calls from many uh service members
thanks to our veterans sacrificing
moving all over the country and we
appreciate that and please if you know a
veteran even if they're not in your
family please let them know about this
we really would love to extend this
offer to those fine folks absolutely uh
real quick before we go to the call uh
to back to the call George uh big news
in the financial world this week I know
it probably hit your little phone with
all your little money alerts that you
get it's a normalized phone
Ken I'm kidding I'm kidding yeah I
didn't mean it that way but now that you
caught that that's fantastic in your
little teeny tiny phone you probably got
an alert about mint which is uh a big
budgeting service owned by Inuit I
believe yeah mint is officially closing
down and it was the it was the largest
free budgeting app out there with 4
million budgeters and at the end of the
year it's closing wow and you know we've
been in the personal finance space for
decades now and you don't want buy some
Fly by Night budget that's here today
and sold tomorrow that was also selling
your data by the way that's how it was
free and they were pitching all yeah and
they were pitching all these loans and
credit card products as to some you
budgets and Loans just don't mix glad I
didn't sign up for me y so I want to
invite all of those who are using mint
uh to go use every dollar you can use it
for free go to every dollar
and we've got the premium version with
all kinds of features and we've got a
killer deal going on right now so go to
every.com and you can go to every.com
George to get our deal that we just
dropped so if that's you and you're
looking for that new budgeting Financial
platform every dollar is going to be a
game changer so we welcome you guys with
open arms um very nice and you have your
own uh URL they gave one to me and so I
figured let's use it I want to give
these the best deal possible call you
should call your mom that's a big deal
she's very proud she should be and we're
not selling their information we don't
sell your data and I guarantee you we'll
never sell you debt products so there's
one bonus look at you I'm telling you
all right let's go to Daniel in
Sacramento California who's patiently
waiting Daniel how can we
help hey guys thanks for taking my call
um so my wife and I we've been really
blessed uh we're currently in a
situation where we have a lot in savings
and the only debt that we have left is
our mortgage which we owe about 164,000
on uh and our savings uh as of today
sits around
168,000 um and it's just been kind of
sitting there because we're not sure
what to do next um and another thing
that is kind of making our decision with
what to do next a little more difficult
is that our our income recently changed
and now uh we're taking in quite a bit
less uh per month and um what happened
so I was hoping to get get your advice
my wife decided to stay at home we had
the the um the I guess Financial
Security to to make that happen um she's
staying at home with the kids and
working part-time now uh and so uh we
have to take we're both teachers and so
we're taking the the teacher health
insurance for our family and it's really
expensive so technically we our our uh
net uh is about 100,000 but we take home
about 5,700 a month okay and what's the
mortgage
payment that's uh 1,400 okay and you've
got a enough in savings that you could
pay off the mortgage today but you're a
little
nervous yes and is that all of your
savings that include your emergency fund
or is this outside of the emergency fund
that's everything okay if I'm in your
shoes Daniel and this is controversial
advice I would get up to where you have
an emergency fund of let's say 3 months
right now maybe closer to six since you
dropped an income then once you hit that
number I'm using the rest of that
savings to clean out the mortgage be
done with
it okay wouldn't 1400 back in your life
make it easier to make this
transition absolutely yeah what's your
other option what were you considering
doing in the meantime would it make
sense to um
throw uh until we we build up that
emergency fun fund uh would it make
sense to throw some money at the at the
mortgage or just keep making the the
single payment every month I mean you
can if I'm in your shoes I'm taking
everything Beyond six months and throw
it at the mortgage that's going to take
your balance down to almost nothing and
so the next few paychecks you'll just
knock out the mortgage with those next
few paychecks so either way you're going
to get there personally I think using
that money now to throw at the mortgage
is going to be very freeing and it's
going to get you real excited you know
when you go from 164,000 mortgage to
$150,000 mortgage I mean sorry down to
you know $15,000 mortgage you're going
to free out how close you are to that
finish line and this transition to where
she's a stay-at home mom becomes it's a
no-brainer you're just like oh all right
we can live like that yeah you you're
going to get that 1,400 bucks back or at
least most of it outside of you know
your property taxes and homeowners
insurance so Daniel what George has
laate out for you is is is forced
momentum you're just going to be at the
point where you're like wow that's all
we have left and we have no house
payment and then to George's point you
go we just gave ourselves a $1,400 raise
now the question
is does that make sense to you a and
then B does it still make you nervous
cutting a check that
large uh yes it does make sense to me
and I think I'd be less nervous once we
have that that emergency fund uh for you
know three to six months you have it
you've got
$168,000 and is it sitting in a savings
account on high yield
savings uh it is in savings account but
it is not in a high yield savings we
have it with just the brick and mortar
bank and it's getting getting
about well makes me sad for him because
I mean right now it's some of the best
savings rates we've ever seen I'm
kidding you're right and you could be
getting four to 5% which again the point
is not to make money on this but it'll
at least make you feel better Daniel the
point the point that George is making
Daniel you already have your mercy fund
so whatever that number is what's six
months of expenses for you guys once you
don't have a mortgage
right now we're actually spending pretty
close to what we're taking in where're
California is really expensive and we
but minus the mortgage payment right oh
yeah minus the mortgage payment little
four grand of expenses yeah about about
four grand okay so let's call it 25
Grand as your emergency fund out of that
164 the rest let's throw at the mortgage
yes see that's what we're getting at you
don't have to wait right so now you do
it all in one Fell
Swoop you have a months emergency fund 3
to 6 months and then you're then you
have you have very little left on that
mortgage that brings you that brings
your mortgage to 25 Grand balance wow
and then the next few paychecks you're
going to knock that thing out by uh you
know the next what six months or
so year yeah you with us
Daniel yes I love that and you know what
if you regret it you can always go back
into debt we like to say that because
it's a good reminder that debt will
always be there to pretend to be your
friend but I don't think you're going to
go back I think it's going to feel feel
real good to own your house free and
clear in California you know how rare
that is
Daniel what will that house be
worth it's close to 500,000 right now oh
boy what's in your your nest eggs oh boy
in retirement uh not much I mean we're
we're still pretty young uh but I think
about
60,000 awesome on your way yeah Babys
set millionair is in your future Dan you
feel good now
buddy yeah I'm excited I want Daniel's I
think you're a little more excited than
his but we got to give him a minute to
let it all soak in we just hit him with
a lot a l and George you practically
yelled at him so we'll talk about that
later I get excited about being mortgage
free Ken what can I say I have no life I
get it you are the man hey always fun to
be with you partner good times great
great show today I want to thank Captain
James old Captain our captain and the
guys in the booth and you America for
listening this is your show this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
oh